public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
boris vélo est l'invité de l'épreuve de
vérité bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous
à ce rendez-vous de public sénat avec
les échos avec radio classique avec l'
agence france-presse vous êtes député
socialiste des landes et vous voulez un
carnet il faut le dire
l'opposition enfin l'un des éléments
forts de l'opposition à emmanuel macron
et au gouvernement d'ailleurs j'ai vu
que vous avez côtoyé le chef de l'état à
l'ena mais apparemment vous n'avez pas
créer de lien à cette époque là un enfin
bon camarade de prostituées cammarano
boghossian bon camarade de bons
camarades de promotion trois grandes
questions pour vous ce soir boris vallot
d'abord est-ce que donald trump joue
avec le feu en reconnaissant bien sûr
jérusalem comme capitale d'israël
l'occasion également pour michaël szames
s dans un instant de vous interroger de
la diplomatie sur le mode macro deuxième
grande question est ce que vous craignez
pour le smic vous le dirai à jean
francis pécresse est alors que vous même
vous allez défendre au mois de janvier
une loi sur l'entreprise mais j'ai vu
qu'il impose notamment un écart maximum
de revenus dans les sociétés enfin
troisième question le ps at il un avenir
stéphanie le rouge vous le demandera et
nous découvrirons ensemble le sondage
opinionway sur ce thème pour l'épreuve
de vérité mais d'abord une toute
première question d'actualité
[Musique]
hommage national à jean d'ormesson
demain hommage grandiose sur les champs
elysées notamment à johnny hallyday le
lendemain samedi l'écrivain et le
rockeur était la france des tons êtes
d'accord
écoutez il était incertain certains
visages de la france ne peut pas dire
que j'en ans maçon et johnny soit tout à
fait le même visage mais c'est sa
révérence dans sa diversité la fois une
culture populaire et puis une culture
plus plus classique mais l'un et l'autre
c'est la france et vous partagez
évidemment c'est cette émotion nationale
où est très palpable de coups des
meneurs on s'est tous réveillés
sidéré et stupéfait par par le décès de
johnny au fond ça j'en ai fini par
imaginer qu'il était immortel way est
malheureusement non encore que il va
rester vivant longtemps à travers toutes
les chansons que vs le chef de l'état en
tous les cas ce sera avec son épouse à
l'entrée de l'église de la madeleine
donc samedi il va s'exprimer même durant
la cérémonie religieuse at on appris
aujourd'hui pour célébrer comme il l'a
dit un héros français est-ce que c'est
justifié selon vous ou un peu trop n'en
a coûté le personnage et de johnny est
considérable donc que pas de querelle
sur ce sujet mme banon et pastorales
parce que vraiment et s'il ya quelqu'un
qui mérite cet hommage national cc
johnnie donc pas mal j'ai envie de vous
dire allez jusqu'au bout alors de de
votre proclamation ce soir à brive alors
pourquoi ne pas reporter le conseil
national du ps qui est justement prévue
samedi puisque le premier candidat
déclaré monsieur carvounas voulait
reporter ce conseil national du ps pour
être en osmose avec les français alors
oui je penserai les socialistes le
saurons à l'unisson des à l'unisson des
français est d'ailleurs tous les
français le sont partout où ils sont
dans le dans le pays et même à
l'étranger la suite de l'épreuve de
vérité avec miguel à metz de public
sénat
[Musique]
vincent michel gossart maurice bellot
est-ce que donald trump joue avec le feu
lorsqu'il reconnaît jérusalem comme
capitale d'israël oui ma décision qui a
été prise et elle était extrêmement
préoccupante elle est extrêmement
préoccupante parce que elle est une
décision unilatérale qui
piétine le droit international les
accords internationaux qui obèrent un
processus de paix dont on sait qu'il est
très incertain mais en même temps il
montre aussi que les états unis
d'amérique s'isole et ça je trouve que
ce n'est pas rassurant dans le dossier
israélo-palestinien mais que ce n'est
pas rassurant d'une manière générale il
lui dit c'est une erreur ancienne qu'il
fallait rattraper une promesse de
campagne qui aujourd'hui met sur la
table erreur de peut-être des différents
présidents américains comme barack obama
ça c'est quelque chose que vous pouvez
aller ça c'est son appréciation c'est
pas la mienne et je veux dire si ses
prédécesseurs qui n'étaient pas moins
avertis que donald trump lui-même sur
les relations internationales n'avaient
pas pris cette décision notamment pour
ne pas se disqualifier comme médiateur
dans un conflit qui ne fait que trop
durer et bien sûr on va écouter sur ce
sujet la déclaration très ferme
aujourd'hui du président de la
république emmanuel macron qui était au
qatar je ne parte en sport cette
décision est gelée
parce que elle contrevient au droit
international elle contrevient aux
résolutions du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies et la france rigueur et sa
position au conseil de sécurité
le scep jérusalem c'est une question de
sécurité internationales
publiques par mou de plus d'un bonnet
ccc voilà c'est les mots que la france
doit avoir dans ces circonstances savez
vous que vous attendez de la part du
président aulas absolument vous disiez
tout à l'heure que là les états unis si
dole la france doit-elle prendre la
place des états unis jouer un peu ce
rôle de médiateur qu'elle avait et
peut-être qu'on doit prendre aujourd'hui
la france bien sûr la france dans
l'europe doit avoir une place dans ce
dans ce débat est dans la situation du
proche orient qui est une situation
extrêmement préoccupante voilà avec que
les relations entre
l'arabie saoudite l'iran il ya quand
même un général un proche orient
moyen-orient qui est ouvert rôle très
trash eh oui mais pour les européens
pour le tout les grands pays qui sont de
bonne volonté pour conduire à la paix le
conseil représentatif des institutions
juives de france a aujourd'hui appelée
emmanuel macron à suivre donald trump se
dire à s'aligner sur sa position est ce
que vous estimez que c'était responsable
de la part du crif je pense que c'est
une erreur d'appréciation de sa part je
n'en sais pas comme ça qu'on ira à la
paix que l'on souhaite tous et le plus
vite possible il ya un autre député qui
demande la même chose à emmanuel macron
c'est le député ed meyer habib là aussi
c'est le rôle d'un député de dire cela
écoutez un député par définition en tout
cas dit ce qu'il pense on a le droit
aussi isolé pour avoir dit je crois
qu'il est très isolé voilà là tu fais
fort de vous interroger sur le fonde sur
la forme on va prendre plusieurs
exemples notamment pour parler de la
diplomatie des manuels macro sur le
voyage en algérie qu'il vient de
réaliser il ya 24 heures il dit il faut
tourner la page du passé qu'est-ce que
ça avec cela vous êtes d'accord oui et
je vais vous dire j'appartiens comme les
évidemment une génération qui n'a pas
connu la guerre d'algérie je me souviens
que cette réflexion sur le regard qu'on
doit avoir sur le passé elle a été celle
de gerhard schröder qui était le premier
responsable les chanceliers allemands
qui n'avait pas connu la guerre il faut
regarder le passé avec lucidité mais se
projeter dans l'avenir ne pas être
enfermé dans des passes et qui ne
veulent pas passer c'est à dire ne pas
être complaisant regarder les choses en
face mais laissez les morts enterrer les
morts un peu c'est ce qu'a dit manuel un
concept qui le répète un en afrique
également en algérie écoutez je croyais
notamment par la voix de l'ambassadeur
de france en algérie qui était père
colin de verdière à l'époque la france a
eu un je vais dire une parole claire sur
sa responsabilité dans un certain nombre
d'événements je pense notamment aux
émeutes de sétif aujourd'hui je crois
que le président de la république
raisons notamment quand il s'adresse à
la jeunesse algérienne de dire regarde
vers l'avenir de la jeunesse cette fois
c'est une question d'une question de
forme si vous voulez bien quand un jeune
lui parle et il parle assez sèchement
c'est vrai il répond qu'est ce que vous
venez mon brouillé avec ça est ce qu'un
président de la république peut dire
cela
côté je sais bien non mais je sais bien
qu'on est souvent conduit à a commenté
le registre
lexical du président république je ne
sais pas tu ne sais pas une première oui
ce n'est pas une première bon c'est le
style du président de la république fait
quoi
il ya un discours sans doute de vérité
mais oui moi je préfère en toute
hypothèse le fond de la forme sauf quand
la forme révèle quelque chose il ya
certains écarts de langage dans d'autres
domaines que le domaine diplomatique qui
disent quelque chose de la vision dans
leurs applications sur la selon vous ben
là encore le cas en l'espèce en jeu je
n'en sais rien d'accord alors moi je
vous dis est-ce que compte tenu de l'âge
qui est celui du président de la
république la génération à laquelle il
s'adresse il a raison de tenir ce
discours là alors avons nous dit quand
même un petit d'optimisme et de et
d'amitié d'amitié forte entre la france
et l'algérie je vous nous dites que la
france rayonne à l'étranger ce soir vous
allez être très critique sur emmanuel
macron dans l'émission il y aura
d'autres occasions mais là c'est le
jugement apparemment de la presse
internationale donc sur la france qui
rayonne je crois qu'on peut convenir que
en effet il a donné donne de la
puissance à la parole française sur la
scène interne à ce que c'est d'être
macro compatible de dire cela je crois
que je crois que vous savez il ya deux
présidents au président une forme de
constance dans la position diplomatique
de la france après les présidents les
incarne de façon différente c'est
françois hollande était aussi très
apprécié par ses partenaires européens
sur la scène sur la scène internationale
voilà je le dis mais moi je ne suis pas
dans la critique systématique quand je
trouve que les choses sont bien je le
dis avec force quand je trouve qu'elles
ne vont pas je lis avec la même force le
fond et la forme on recommence cette
fois sur le style comparé aux services
publics la télé française notamment il
parle de honte pour nos concitoyens
c'est ce qu'il aurait dit lors d'une
réunion à l'elysée haute en terme de
gouvernance et de critiquer l'attitude
des dirigeants du service public
notamment de l'audiovisuel public est ce
que ça vous l'entendez ou pas écouté
le chef de l'état la ministre de la
culture a droit d'avoir une opinion sur
le service public partageait cette audi
audiovisuelle je
partageais de mahler tâche pas cette
opinion je ne partage pas dans justement
dans ses excès de forme j'étais pas
c'est à cette
réunion donc je veux dire il y avait que
des députés de la majorité donc voila
moi je sais pas si les propos ont été
tenus de telle ou telle meilleur s'il
advenait confirmé je voulais plus me
avec 7 avec cette dureté là je la trouve
excessive est assez ayasse et
inconvenante et puis au fond ouf pas
très pas très respectueuse de tous ceux
qui à france télévisions travaillent et
font des magazines des des programmes de
vives inquiétudes parce que vous allez
vous battre sur ce dossier mais moi je
me battrai pour que par exemple on ait
une information et des magazines
d'information indépendants et qu'ils
aient les moyens de leur indépendance il
ya eu d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
préoccupations ces derniers jours sur ce
sujet la saisie sujets sur lesquels on
sera vigilant mais j'ai l'euro à quel
point a au point de s'y opposer ou au
point de se saisir de ces questions là
dans l'hémicycle quand l'occasion s'en
offrir est-ce que vous avez l'impression
que le président de la république de
faire le grand ménage
moi vous allez enfin voila je bien
commenté beaucoup de choses mais je
connais pas je ne suis pas oui le celui
qui lit dans dans le marre des phrases
sorties comme ça
ouais la forme toujours continue cette
fois sur la victoire peut être annoncés
dimanche d'où peut-être nouveau futur
président des républicains les nerfs
laurent wauquiez sur la forme sur le
fond il vous fait peur écoutez on aura
manifestement des désaccords politiques
majeurs
majeur et on aura des occasions de
confrontation nombreuses sur beaucoup de
sujets économiques sociaux sociétaux
et bien c'est ça la démocratie c'est ça
le débat démocratique à chacun de
convaincre du bien-fondé ce qu'il pense
et de dénoncer ce qu'ils croient injuste
dangereux pour le pays pour la cohésion
du pays puis dire la façon dont il voit
la société et son avenir est-ce que
selon vous en parler du parti socialiste
1 dans la troisième partie de l'émission
mais est-ce que sont loués manuel macro
on doit craindre de laurent wauquiez qui
fait une campagne assez à droite est ce
que d'une certaine manière ça va pas
renforcer le chef de l'état dans sa
position centrale
moi je veux pas avoir de mal je nourris
je vais pas de spéculation je n'en sais
rien ce que je peux vous dire au delà la
question précise que vous me posez c'est
que on a besoin dans ce pays d'une
démocratie vivante avec des oppositions
avec la possibilité pour ces oppositions
je parle donc d'une gauche jeune
droitier aux attentes absolument on a
besoin de débat et pas d'un grand centre
où tout se vaut dray voilà moi je crois
que tout ne se vaut pas est ce que on
peut dire aujourd'hui que manuel macron
a tué cette gauche et sa droite c'est
trop compliqué mais je le crois pas elle
est un anesthésient en tout cas pour ce
qui est de la gauche parce que elle sort
d'une défaite qui est considérable mais
enfin elle est fidèle à ses valeurs à
ses convictions dans l'histoire
l'histoire longue de la gauche elle a
ses combats et aujourd'hui on est une
opposition qui est une opposition
intransigeant quand il y va de la
justice de l'égalité les principes
républicains une gauche responsable
parce qu'on ne propose pas n'importe
quoi non les propositions que nous
formulons dans les amendements que nous
déposons et puis une gauche imaginative
parce que je voulais en aura sans doute
tout à l'heure eh bien on formule des
propositions qui nous paraît de regarder
le monde de demain non pas avec lunettes
d'hier mais avec celle d'aujourd'hui on
va en parler dans un instant
effectivement et notamment des mesures
que vous proposez pour l'entreprise une
question justement sur une recrue
récente du maquereau nisme c'est votre
ancien camarade socialiste olivier du
soft qui leur est d'ailleurs socialiste
en tous les cas camarades je ne sais pas
en tous les cas vous avez démontré votre
dur pour lui puisque vous avez estimé
qu'il avait craché au visage des députés
socialistes il s'explique aujourd'hui
dans le monde le nouveau secrétaire
d'état à la fonction publique et il
défend les mesures économiques celles
sur l'éducation les universités
la politique de macron n'étant rien
éloignée de l'idéal que je poursuis dit
olivier dussopt le chef de l'état et le
gouvernement sont progressistes est-ce
que vous contestez son appréciation
écoutez moi je trouve stupéfiant qu'on
soit capable en une semaine de changer
radicalement d'expression sur les mêmes
objets les mêmes politiques vous savez
moi au fond ce que dit olivier dussopt
pts m'intéresse assez peu oui j'ai eu
des mots durs parce que j'ai été blessé
je le dis franchement le haut salat
manifestement d'avoir été viré au civil
a le droit d'avoir sa part d'humanité et
la politique pas forcément je veux dire
déshumanisé et moi ce qui m'intéresse
plus c'est ce que dit ce débauchage de
la façon dont l'exécutif considère le
parlement considère les oppositions 714
d'attrition du débat démocratique de
disqualification des oppositions et bien
c'est une pierre supplémentaire mais qui
grands qui ne grandit pas ceux qui ont
pris cette décision là parce que vous
savez moi le cynisme en politique j'ai
jamais trouvé que c'était une vertu donc
c'est du débauchage points et ça dit
quelque chose je ne fais pas le répéter
de la façon dont tu es considéré de se
considérer les institutions le parlement
et les oppositions merci beaucoup un
mail à celui de l'épreuve de vérité
maintenant avec jean francis pécresse le
directeur de la rédaction de radio
classique
[Musique]
agent français ce soir michel bonsoir
boris vallauris que vous êtes inquiet
pour le smic alors qu'un rapport d'un
groupe d'experts
préconise de mettre fin à la
revalorisation automatique de ce salaire
minimum
je vais faire je progresse et moi j'ai
bien compris le sens de la proposition
je dois vous dire quand j'ai vu la
composition
de ce groupe d'experts j'en avais les
conclusions parce que on sait depuis
longtemps ce que celle des recettes
pense d'une ancienne économiste de
gauche n'est pas encore officiellement à
gauche philippe affaire l'avait renvoyé
la momie catalogués à gauche bien sûr
mais finalement de moins en moins vous
savez la domination culturelle du
libéralisme où flottent des 35 à fond
elle progresse mais oui mais il ya des
gens qui changent d'avis on en a évoqué
un autre tout à l'heure c'est parce que
nous sommes d'avis qu'il est dans la
continuité mais on va on va pas faire
tout le débat sur lui oui oui non mais
je suis parfaitement d'accord avec vous
me posez la question de savoir si leur
suis inquiet
la question c'est de savoir quelles sont
les intentions du gouvernement il ya un
rapport il ya les intentions du
gouvernement moi j'ai cru comprendre de
la ministre qu'elle était attachée à la
négociation on va l'écouter on écoute tu
écouteras elle va le dire et le même
voilà c'était hier muriel pénicaud qui
en fait effectivement défend la notion
après on verra les détails à venir la
notion du salaire minimum smic est une
pierre angulaire de notre modèle social
français nous sommes tous convaincus que
le travail doit être rémunéré par un
salaire juste et décent nous pensons que
c'est un sujet d'importance nous devons
prendre le temps de la réflexion de la
concertation ne vont pas nous précipiter
mais nous devons pouvoir en discuter en
toute sérénité en maintenant le cap de
l'eso le caractère essentiel du smic
pour le pouvoir d'achat et pour la
cohésion sociale en discuter et
l'opinion ce matin dit enfin écrit que
le gouvernement serait ouvert à une
modification de la règle d'indexation du
smic pour faire en sorte qu'ils soient
qu'ils évoluent moins vite dans les
années à venir écoutez moi je vous dire
le gouvernement proclame qu'il faut que
le travail paye le dis à toutes
occasions et moi je suis pour que le
travail paye et je dirais même qu'il
paye bien aujourd'hui la question c'est
de savoir si on vit bien avec le smic si
le travail de quelqu'un qui est au smic
paye bien
je crois que chacun a la réponse c'est
non et ce que ça disqualifie une
réflexion sur le coût du travail sur la
compétitivité je ne crois pas d'ailleurs
on sait qu'aujourd'hui au niveau du smic
avec les baisses de charges parce qu'il
vend du cic en baisse de charge il aura
quasiment plus de cotisations patronales
au niveau au niveau du smic alors qu'un
certain nombre d'économistes si on peut
aller plus loin il peut y avoir des
cotisations sociales négatives je sais
pas si c'est juridiquement possible je
n'en sais rien mais comprenez bien que
la question de la compétitivité la
question du coût du travail ça n'est
qu'une partie de l'équation de notre
compétitivité il ya la question de la
formation de la productivité horaire des
travailleurs on allume une des
productivités les plus fortes de l'union
européenne regardez le coût du travail
par exemple dans l'industrie est bien le
coût du travail français est repassé
derrière le coût du travail des ouvriers
allemands ça dit quelque chose est ce
que ce sujet au moment où la croissance
repart est primordial moi je fais le
lien entre la réflexion sous jacente
c'est à dire au fond on augmente plus le
smic et on augmente le pouvoir d'achat
par une prime d'activité d'abord de
faire une simple remarque le smic ses
dividendes personnes la prime d'activité
c'est moins de 3 millions de personnes
oui bien proposera beaucoup moins de
monde mais est-ce à l'employeur ou à la
solidarité nationale à faire en sorte
que le travail paye c'est la même
question qui est posée avec
l'augmentation de la csg des retraités
ont dit qu'en fait on va augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat des actifs pour partie
par la csg des retraités qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire que si votre
patron vous refuser une augmentation
vous allez la prendre dans le
portefeuille de votre grand mère moi ça
ne me paraît pas répondre à la question
en tout cas l'ambition de du travail qui
paie alors il faut qu'on travaille sur
la qualification réveillé par un grand
plan de formation c'est une idée que
l'érable et modalités mais que l'on peut
accompagner parce que nous avons un
chômage de masse qui est un cheval de
nos qualifs tout petit correctif
peut-être pour les téléspectateurs c'est
pas des millions de personnes le spx est
démis en personne indirectement c'est
dire que quand il est bien sûr
revalorise ça explique sa souche ça
touche 10 millions terrible voilà
millions de salaires qui sont hostiles
et juste au dessus mais c'est je crois
un million et demi de personnes vivent
explique vous allez me rectifié au mois
de janvier vous allez défendre une
proposition de loi qui préconise un
écart maximum entre les pour revenus les
plus bas dans une entreprise et les
revenus les plus élevés
de combien devrait être être cet écart
on a souvent parlé d'un écart de 1 à 20
est ce que c'est la bonne jauge à
l'avant d'abord c'est vraiment pas
l'essentiel de la proposition que nous
allons formuler mais c'était une mesure
alors on va parler des vraies et
précisément parce que c'était en réalité
l'une des mesures qui permet de se poser
la question à quoi sert entreprises du
batteur partage de la valeur ajoutée
dans l'entreprise nous avons fait le
choix d'un acté le principe mais de
renvoyer la concertation concertation
qui devra être conduite par le
gouvernement le soin de déterminer cet
écart là bas quand même avancé un
chiffre quand même non mais écoutez je
peux je vais pas vous répondre dans la
mesure où l'idée c'est qu'il y ait une
concertation oui mais pas de cette
concertation 1 ab non non non à 20 40 et
je suis pas capable de vous répondre il
ya des gens qui lisent 1 à 12 est-ce que
qu'elle et avec laquelle giraud rien
acquis 10 1 à 30 je dois vous dire que
les les guerriers vous choque vous vous
savez aujourd'hui on a des écarts qui
sont 1 100 1 à 2 cents là où on est dans
des temps des dents les choses qui sont
tout à fait inconcevable et qui ne
reflète en rien l'utilité que celui qui
touche aux scellera à dans l'entreprise
par rapport à celui versé par à d'autres
univers fait de même il est même arrivé
à l'attaqué parce qu'il ya un certain
nombre de conseils migration de voter
contre ces rémunérations là mais ils
n'étaient pas en situation de les
bloquer et puis dans cette proposition
doit il ya une autre proposition qui
consiste à sur le modèle allemand au
fond donner aux salariés la moitié des
sièges dans les conseils
d'administration des entreprises en
allemagne c'est le conseil de
surveillance mais c'est à peu près le
même pouvoir
dans les entreprises françaises vous
vous dites au delà de 5000 salariés
est-ce que c'est pas un signe très
négatif que l'on enverrait sur ces
grandes entreprises ait des
investisseurs étrangers c'est ça c'est
une réflexion qui me surprend on
passerait de temps mais on passe notre
temps à nous vanter le modèle allemand à
nous vanter le modèle les modèles
scandinaves mais jamais quand il s'agit
quand il s'agit de mesures qui relèvent
de la côte détermination quel est
l'esprit c'est ce que d'être une région
la france n est pas du tout le même là
bas et ici eh bien eh bien eh bien tu es
libyen et bien précisément c'est le
matin changement de culture un
changement de culture que nous voulons
inaugurer avec avec cette côté derby
nation à la française qui est en tout
cas en proportion bien inférieur à ce
qui se passe en allemagne donc on est
sur un chemin oui on ne brusque pas les
entreprises mais le pari que nous
faisons c'est de dire dans cette
modification qui est devenu déloyale
avec une financiarisation de l'économie
qui est importante avec une croissance
qui se heurte à la finitude du monde
quel est le rôle de l'entreprise comme
levier de transformation entreprise
c'est un levier puissant de
transformation en bien comme en mal de
créer de la richesse pour créer des
richesses mais aussi de créer de la
richesse en se préoccupant c'est ce
qu'on appelle les externalités négatives
conséquences environnementales sociales
économiques et ça c'est une vraie
révolution hockey qui qui qui paraît peu
mais qui en réalité change les
mentalités et c'est une reprise de 2,2
pouvoir sur le court du mondialisation
dont le principe pivot de la justice et
la loyauté et la co détermination à quoi
elle sert dans l'entreprise elle sert à
dire l'entreprise d'une certaine manière
n'est pas la propriété des ses
actionnaires actionnaires ils sont
propriétaires des titres qui leur
accorde de par la loi un certain nombre
de prérogatives et de droit c'est un
bien commun il n'y a pas que des
processions là pas du tout il n'y a pas
que des actionnaires qui sont exposés à
un risque dans l'entreprise les salariés
notamment le son et quelle est l'idée de
cette côte détermination de dire au fond
on va résister au court termisme des
marchés qui fait souvent obstacle au
projet de stratégie industrielle entre
eux qui le dis c'est pas des
bolchéviques pas trompé jean-louis beffa
on est un des grands promoteurs cette
idée elle germe dans la société civile
parmi les chefs d'entreprise les
syndicats les universitaires depuis bien
longtemps moi je crois que c'est un acte
de confiance dans l'entreprise et que
c'est un des déterminants fondamentaux
de la compétitivité des entreprises dans
les années à venir vous voyez bien ce
qu'on va vous opposer à ça c'est le
retour de la pas assez la cogestion pas
de la côte détermination vous vous dites
qu détermination mais c'est de la co
gestion au fond ce que vous voulez c'est
de la co détermination qu'au décès dans
les instances sur les instances qui
existe dans lequel il ya déjà un certain
nombre d'administrateurs salariés et
nous avons des exemples partout en
europe et dans le monde où ça fonctionne
et dans des pays dont on le rappelle
souvent que ce qui fait sa force et la
qualité de son aigle au 12e donc nous
faisons ce pari là j'en pense
aujourd'hui même eurostat qui est
l'organisme statistique européen a
publié une un chiffre qui est assez
accablant pour pour pour la france dire
que pour la première fois la france en
termes de taux de prélèvements
obligatoires est passé devant le
danemark nous sommes les champions
d'europe il probablement d'ailleurs les
champions du monde des prélèvements
obligatoires en 2016 c'est l'héritage de
la droite évidemment mais de la gauche
aussi beaucoup est ce que vous êtes fier
de ce chiffre moi je d'abord je
disqualifie pas a priori l'impôt je
pense que il ya eu une disqualification
de l'impôt qui a commencé dans les
années 80 de la progressivité de l'impôt
même les familles aujourd'hui dit qu'il
faut restaurer la progressivité de
l'impôt parce que ça nous plaît lampions
alors faut s'en féliciterait se dire moi
je veux dire deux choses
première chose c'est que ce qui compte
pour rembourser notamment les dettes
c'est la croissance c'est générer des
recettes fiscales qui viendront combler
ses dettes ses déficits donc on a besoin
de relancer cette machine économique
ensuite il ne faut pas être addict à la
dépense publique moi je ne suis pas de
ceux qui pensent que l'on peut
durablement vivre au-dessus de ses
moyens mais je dis que le rythme auquel
on doit faire c'est l'économie qui
permettent ensuite faire un certain
nombre de un certain nombre de baisses
d'impôts doivent être compatibles avec
le retour de la croissance voilà je
crois que cette croissance la regarde et
on a 7 milliards d'euros de plus par
rapport à la loi de finances initiale de
recettes en 2017 on aura en année pleine
en 2008 10 milliards de plus lire c'est
quand même des chiffres qui sont
aujourd'hui important et qui permettent
ensuite à voir l'état des latitudes ah
bon on a une cagnotte là où nous dit ben
on a des recettes fiscales ont fait une
cagnotte du kenya je crois pas vrai
qu'elle soit beaucoup plus important
qu'on puisse parler de cagnotte mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que nous avons
des recettes fiscales en donnant sont
liées à la croissance et je ne me désole
pas qui est de la croissance
est ce qu est ce qu on peut faire une
économie croissance justement avoir une
économie de croissance avec des
prélèvements obligatoires pareil vous
parliez de l'allemagne de ce qui est bon
à prendre là bas
l'écart de prélèvements obligatoires si
tu as cru justement avec avec
l'allemagne qui sont eux à 40 % de
prélèvements obligatoires moi j'entends
bien effectivement ce que vous ce que
vous dites sur les économies de dépenses
publiques mais ça ne se fait jamais
c'était diront on a toujours une
augmentation de prélèvements
obligatoires jamais d'économie de vraies
économies de dépenses publiques c'est ce
qu'il faut économiser vous ces fours est
ce que vous préconisez de de faire de
vraies économies dans la dépense
publique et écoutez moi je crois que par
exemple on a fait une dépense fiscale de
4 milliards et demi pour les 10% les
plus riches je pense que c'est une
dépense fiscale qui dès qui n'est pas
qui n'est pas utile on aurait pu décider
de baisser les impôts d'autres
catégories doivent de fait des
annulations ben on a beaucoup fait déjà
mais où était voyez vous dites qu'on me
laisse pas suffisamment les impôts que
vous me dites à l'instant qu'on a déjà
beaucoup fait donc voilà ce que je veux
dire c'est que l'aménagement des cantons
quand on regarde la question de l'état
moi c'est l'expérience que j'ai acquise
qu'on a un sujet qui nourrit sans doute
la crise de la démocratie qui est une
crise de la décision publique voilà je
trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui
ne marchent pas et j'ai eu pas que le
président de la république aux
administrés dit quelque chose pour que
pour que ça se passe ça veut dire que
dans la façon de fond qu'on soit le rôle
de la puissance publique on doit se
poser la question de son efficacité de
sa modernisation de sa numérisation
voilà moi je vais pas vous répondre
comme ça est ce qu'il y ait moins besoin
à l'hôpital ah je regarde et je me dis
banon est vraiment un besoin à l'hôpital
veut dire en même temps en face de ses
dépenses publiques on a quoi on a aussi
des services qui sont productifs parce
que notre économie elles bénéficient de
nos infrastructures elles bénéficient de
de notre de notre système de systèmes de
santé et si on réduit ça il ya des
chances aussi pour qu'on réduise notre
compétitivité vous avez beaucoup
critiqué la politique fiscale du
gouvernement vous avez aussi dénoncé la
les ordonnances sur la loi travail
aujourd'hui de toutes parts on nous dit
que cela renforce ses mesures renforcent
l'attractivité de la france est ce que
vous le reconnaissez aujourd'hui moi ce
que j'observe c'est que avant même cette
ordonnance la croissance est repartie
l'économie créé depuis 16 mois
nouveau de l'emploi et je constate que
le nombre d usines qui ferment devenu
inférieur aux nombreuses usines qui
ouvre bon donc pour l'instant je vous
dire je ne vois pas des faits liés à ces
ordonnances et d'ailleurs on a eu des
débats un peu contradictoire menée le
premier ministre qui a dit nous allons
par cet homme par ses ordonnances mettre
fin au chômage de masse et dès le
lendemain on a et le vice-président du
medef et la mini du travail elle même
qui on dit il n'ya pas attendre de
vagues dedans gauche le sujet que nous
avons c'est que beaucoup des
investissements étrangers en france
aujourd'hui sont des investissements qui
sont très capitalistique et très peu
intensifs en main d'oeuvre ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on a observé tout
toutes ces dernières années donc
et c'est pas le fait seulement deux de
la france c'est le fait aussi des autres
pays européens la question c'est comment
on a aussi des investissements qui sont
intensifs en main d'oeuvre et la
question de ce point de vue là pardon
mais de la relocalisation est importante
et chaude si je veux juste continuer
pour sur l'environnement économique des
entreprises savaient que l'essentiel des
investissements étrangers en france sont
le fait d'entreprises qui sont déjà
emprunté en france et qui apprécient la
qualité de l'environnement économique
sociale de ce pays alors la question
dernière question peut-être parce
qu'elle est à bâle est importante pour
la gouvernance et pour l'avenir de la
zone euro ce qui se passe en allemagne
encore une fois pour le goût d'allemagne
mais aujourd'hui même le spd allemand
c'est-à-dire le parti social démocrate
allemand doit se prononcer sur la
question de savoir s'ils vont discuter
avec angela merkel pour la formation
d'une grande coalition allemande est ce
que vous êtes favorable à ce que le spd
forme cette coalition avec l'allemagne
enfin avec la
je suis je suis assez
c'est quand même une question qui est
compliqué je ne connais pas ce que
serait le pacte gouvernementale entre le
spd et et la chancelière je crois que ce
qu'avait suggéré martin schulz faire une
cure d'opposition qui nous permettraient
nous tous partis sociaux-démocrates de
nous interroger de savoir pourquoi nous
en sommes là serait pas une mauvaise une
mauvaise chose ensuite on a besoin que
il ya de la stabilité politique en
allemagne voilà mais je crois que le spd
devrait quand même s'interroger sur
notre faiblesse européenne et mondiale
parce qu'elle a des conséquences elle
aimait partager ses dribbles on va
parler du parti socialiste dans un
instant on a beaucoup parlé de votre loi
sur l'entreprise que vous allez défendre
donc au mois de janvier vous en êtes
l'auteur mais je vois que je ne suis pas
là l'outaouais c'est un travail
collectif et le travail de tout le monde
louait le beau et tout seigneur tout
honneur va miner le petit porte étendard
dominique potier une hypothèque et v4 à
vis ici depuis longtemps et le député
qui est à l'origine de ce travail
collectif mais vous avez vu que bruno le
maire va lui-même déposé un texte une
loi sur les entreprises justement pour
que les salariés notamment le soient
mieux représentés vous pourriez pas vous
entendre là un texte dynamo s'est elle
bien on vient si si ça si le
gouvernement émet sur notre autre loi un
avis favorable on s'en réjouira bon et
inversement il vous resterait jury à wil
800 joignez 8,16 à ceux qui viennent
dans une proposition de loi puisqu'il
est sur le bureau de l'assemblée moi je
ne sais pas ce que dans la peau dans le
projet de loi du gouvernement merci
beaucoup jean-francis dernière mme
skalli deux les points de vérité on va
donc parler du parti socialiste
aujourd'hui avec stéphanie le rouge de
la fp
l'épreuve de vérité avec life fait
stéphanie
bonsoir alors question sur le parti
socialiste
est-ce qu'il a un avenir est ce qu'il a
aimé venir si la question que vous me
posez
deux chapitres mais vous pouvez
commencer à répondre non mais écoutez la
question est en effet posée la question
est possible il en a aucun si on ne se
mobilise pas pour le redresser pour le
refonder si on ne se pose pas la
question de pourquoi nous en sommes là
quelle société nous voulons est ce que
nous sommes encore capables d'être une
force transformatrice de la société
voilà donc cette question allait poser
mais je fais le chemin qui est incertain
qui est exigeant qui demande beaucoup
d'humilité beaucoup de détermination à
de participer leur fondation de ce parti
alors on a un sondage à vous proposer
exclusif pour cette émission réalisée
par opinionway c'était pas un dopant
pour vous ce soir à boris vélo mais on
va regarder en détail les deux questions
qui ont été posées
première question diriez vous que le ps
vit une crise durable les français
répondent dans leur ensemble oui à
74% une crise passagère 17% notons que
les sympathisants ps
10e crise durable à 56%
réaction écoutez je voyage je serais
bien incapable de vous dire avec
certitude que leur est un produit à
sanaa alors crise durable alors vous
auriez dit on est dans une crise dans la
majorité des années dans une grille ans
on est dans une crise qui peut être
durable ça dépend de notre capacité à
nous entendre à nous parler mobilisés le
ps peut être sur pied d'ici 2022 je
crois qu'il le peut c'est une question
de volonté de détermination et d'audace
deuxième question opinionway qui pour
incarner l'avenir du parti socialiste à
leur opinion et a proposé des noms 1 et
les résultats ils sont pas folichons là
pour najat vallaud belkacem 10 % pour
françois hollande 7% petit 7% également
pour stéphane le foll olivier faur 2%
luc carvounas candidats en le site est
tout à l'heure 1 % et aucun des noms
cités
71% il va falloir chercher votre avenir
au delà de de votre carnet d'adressés
habituel
enfin certains
écoutent et est ce que vous pensez qu'on
peut avoir plus de force que cela
aujourd'hui dans la situation dans
laquelle on est c'est une défaite qui
est considérable qui est mesuré le bien
qui est à la fois une défaite organique
c'est à dire celle d'un parti et c'est
une défaite probablement doctrine c'est
la mise en cause d'une offre politique
socialiste social démocrate de gauche
voilà il ya cette question là et c'est
pour ça que le travail de refondation il
est d'autant plus exigeant d'autant plus
compliqué mais ce que je sens dans le
parti pour rencontrer beaucoup de
militants partout en france mais
également en dehors du parti socialiste
dans les milieux intellectuels le
chercheur syndicaux associatifs je sens
ce désir que reimer une offre politique
dans cet espace entre jean luc mélenchon
et manuellement à l'ordre dans le
sondage les sympathisants ps était un
peu plus indulgent on va dire donc najat
se voyait crédité de 29% des réponses
on vous a
déjà interrogé plusieurs fois sur ce
sujet est ce que vous vous pensez
qu'elle serait susceptible de se lancer
dans cette es vous lui poserez la
question jeu j'en sais rien d'accord on
savait rien n'ont pensé que j'étais
mieux informé que d'autres mais n'ont
d'ailleurs que vous l'encouragez si vous
avez en la matière c'est une décision
qui est très personnel si j'étais très
personnel qui doit être la sienne
d'abord qu'elles soient positives ou
négatives et moi je ne veux pas peser de
quelques manières que ce soit dans sa
dans cette décision c'est que je suis de
ce point de vue là un militant parmi
d'autres et puis
najat vallaud belkacem est très
féministe donc prend les décisions mais
vous soumettre à vous même les questions
effectivement et les noms de la question
de ce sondage qui pour incarner l'avenir
du parti socialiste alors vous avez le
droit de faire par exemple votre tiercé
aux votre trio de tête qu'est ce que
vous pensez par exemple de la
candidature de lui car j'ai
bien compris toutes les questions je les
anticipe d'ailleurs je crois qu'il ya
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs dans votre
proposition il n'y a que lui carvounas
canada soit candidat
moi je le côtoie comme comme
parlementaire c'est un collègue groupe
nouvelle gauche c'est quelqu'un
d'intelligent d'enthousiastes donc vous
savez moi je me prononce en général
c'est comme ça dans les courses 1 quand
on connaît les partants d'accord il y a
quelqu'un qui est peut-être sur la ligne
d'arrivée et de départ d'arrivée je ne
sais pas en tout les cas c'est françois
hollande il a dit qu'il avait lui repris
l'entraînement comment est ce que vous
avez reçu cette petite phrase de
françois hollande est ce que vous mangez
du rôle qu'il joue aujourd'hui alors
j'ai vu ça mais je ne suis plus le
contexte dans lequel elle répondait à un
étudiant a oui mais sur quelles
questions je crois pas que c'était sur
le sujet de la politique et qui
reprenait l'entraînement à la question
varie de lui il a répondu et d'apparat
une métaphore footballistique mais la
question était bien politique
il était président de la république il a
une expérience qu'il fait valoir avec la
liberté qui est la sienne c'est tout
après je pense que notamment les médias
qui ont cet appétit la lui en prêtent
peut-être plus que que la réalité
d'accord et vous votre sentiment à votre
opinion votre question c'est votre ping
a exprimé jean luc mélenchon a parlé
dans une
interview ya pas très longtemps des
fantômes de la vieille gauche dont le ps
fait selon lui partie il pointait
notamment les contradictions qui peut y
avoir au sein du parti qui peuvent
s'illustrer à l'assemblée où il ya eu
des votes différents sur la question de
la confiance au gouvernement qui peuvent
s'illustrer au sénat où on a un
président de groupe qui dit qu'il n'est
pas dans l'opposition est ce qu'il ya
aujourd'hui un problème de cohérence au
ps
le parti socialiste a perdu dans toutes
ses dimensions
a perdu dans tous ces courants a perdu
donc d'une certaine heure toutes ces
offres politiques dans leur diversité
finalement ça aurait été plus simple si
on avait jeté par an par exemple les
frondeurs ou les hollandais vous savez
il ya des ascendants dans tout ça est
très compliqué mais avait gagné en
aurait eu un chemin là au fond on est
face à un chemin qui est un chemin
d'incertitude
c'est pour ça que nous avons besoin nous
interroger sur tous les grands sujets
sur notre rapport à la mondialisation
sous notre rapport à l'europe sur les
grandes mutations du travail qui vont
ébranler non seulement une entreprise
mais tous les cadres de régulation du
marché du travail on doit s'interroger
sur la question environnementale sur la
définition même de ce qu'est la
croissance on va se poser beaucoup de
beaucoup de questions moi je crois pour
faire la tournée quand même des
militants qui ont leur histoire qui ont
leur lorgues où leur
les élus auxquels ils ont cru dans
lesquelles ils croient je crois notre
capacité à transcender nos différences
pour être radicalement moderne voilà moi
je crois que là qui je sais pas si on
est une vieille gauche qui refuse avec
s'accrocher au passé mais moi ce que je
veux dire c'est que notre horizon ni
toujours devant nous une autre exigence
à l'est de se projeter de se projeter
dans l'avenir et une question qu'on se
lâche un jour pendant la question des
rats au nom de qui on parle et je crois
que la différence notamment du
gouvernement on ne doit pas faire de la
politique seulement pour quelques-uns
mais pour le plus grand nombre il ne
doit pas se satisfaire d'une france qui
est coupée en deux avec des inégalités
qui sont considérables et qui fracturent
socialement économiquement et
politiquement le pays il ya une question
qui va revenir dans l'actualité la
semaine prochaine qui est celle de notre
dame des landes puisque le rapport
commandé par gouvernement on va être
remis sur la question la maire de nantes
socialiste a redit récemment qu'elle
était pour cet aéroport enfin le
déménagement l'aéroport pardon
quelle est votre position sur ce dossier
emblématique moi c'est assez
c'est un dossier que je connais très mal
je vais être franc la leçon que j'en
tire c'est qu'un projet qui n'est 60 ans
avant de sortir de terre il ya toutes
les chances de subir quelques
déconvenues et de se heurter quelques à
quelques contradictions ce qui pose
d'ailleurs d'une manière générale la
question de savoir comment on conduit
des grands projets qui vont
nécessairement poser des questions
environnementales d'aménagement etc la
maire de nantes jean guy lacroix bonne
connaisseuse de son environnement de son
territoire donc j'ai plutôt envie de lui
faire confiance et je crois qu'on doit
être capable en tout cas si le projet de
notre dame des landes est confirmé pour
faire un projet absolument exemplaire
sur le plan de la question
environnementale sur la question
environnementale justement on a constaté
ces derniers temps que les grands
leaders ce qui reste en tous les cas
europe ecologie les verts penche plutôt
du côté de benoît hamon alors que jean
luc mélenchon également leur fait les
yeux doux est ce que vous vous êtes
totalement hors jeu dans cette galaxie
là aujourd'hui mais pas du tout non non
moi je vais vous dire je ne le crois pas
et on a dans nos rangs delphine batho
qui est le fer de lance du groupe en
matière environnementale avec une vraie
vision c'est à dire que contre
l'aéroport le déménagement cliqué qui a
ses arguments en effet et qui sur la
question des hydrocarbures da fin d'une
économie carbone et à porter le débat au
nom du groupe nouvelle gauche à
l'assemblée qu'à une vraie vision sous
le thème comment on concilie l'exigence
environnementale et la nécessité d'un
développement industriel donc non je
crois pas du tout qu'on soit je pense
que le parti socialiste aujourd'hui il
est nécessairement écologistes ne par
rapport à jean luc mélenchon et benoît
benoît
mais qui quelle est votre clique aider
votre question écoutez il le revendique
haut et fort et les immigrants jamais
mélenchon mais c'est aussi celle qui
entend benoît avons eu beaucoup
d'écologie beaucoup mais qu'est ce que
je vais est-ce que je vais me désole que
la question écologique soit
centrale dans un certain nombre d'offres
politique je crois pas je crois que la
question écologique est le vôtre
écologique et sociale parce que voyez je
parle d' inégalités l'une des
principales et l'égalité contre lesquels
on aura à se battre c'est la question
des inégalités face aux risques
environnementaux et notamment benoît
hamon a lancé son mouvement enfin
relancé son mouvement générations ce
week-end est ce que vous pensez qu'il
peut
vous faire de l'ombre à ce que voilà ces
mouvements
vous empêcher de vous épanouir je crois
pas que ça vous empêchera du tout de
nous épanouir au fond peut même y avoir
d'émulation
et puis avoir une compétition saine dans
les idées dans les projets il y aura des
sujets sur lesquels on sera d'accord
d'autres ne sera pas d'accord
benoît hamon il vient du parti
socialiste il a perdu les élections
je l'évoquais tout à l'heure comme tout
le parti socialiste toutes ses
dimensions donc il a lui aussi ce
travail à faire moi je reproche à
personne de chercher une voie pour s'en
sortir à dire vrai j'aurais préféré que
l'on le faso même si c'est plus
incertain même si c'est dans le cadre du
parti socialiste avec les militants qui
ont fait la campagne de benoît hamon je
les fait c'est ainsi je crois pas que
l'on soit en concurrence et moi je suis
quelqu'un de très déterminé je peux vous
dire qu'au parti socialiste il ya
beaucoup de gens très déterminé il y a
non mais vous avez l'avenir en commun la
bono dit avec benoît hamon et je dis
qu'on est je dis que moi je sais pas
changé en commun je dis juste que au
sein du parti socialiste avant de se
poser la question des alliances
extérieures dont je faisais question des
alliances intérieur sommes-nous campagne
de nous réconcilier avec nous mêmes
c'est vrai que vous êtes ce qu'il a oui
entre les deux divisions moi j'ai fait
quand même une campagne électorale
de proximité dans un territoire qui
était très ancré à gauche d'encrés
weiland histoire avec le parti
socialiste et beaucoup de gens aux
élections présidentielles nous pas voter
pour le candidat du parti socialiste et
vous savez ce qu'il me disait me disais
vous avez été incapable de vous entendre
et ça ça résonne aujourd'hui de mon
esprit de jeudi ce que nous devons faire
c'est nous entendre accepter de se
parler accepter de doute et de revenir
sur un certain nombre de certitudes
d'être convaincu par celui avec lequel
on est en désaccord pour construire un
projet commun voilà vous êtes favorable
à ce que les amis de nos amis
quitte le parti je suis favorable la
clarté
la duplicité elle peut faire du mal et
je crois que personne n'a envie de faire
de mal à personne
et je sais pas quand je sais je sais pas
quelle est sa situation je n'ai pas eu
l'occasion d'en parler avec lui donc
voilà ce que ce que je crois c'est que
si on s'engage dans une démarche de
reconstruction du parti socialiste il
faut pas le faire à moitié d'accord donc
l'avenir existe encore le ps a encore un
avenir c'était la question qu'on vous
pose est est-ce que selon vous je crois
avoir répondu oui vous avez répondu oui
c'est ce que je me souviens gasquet
selon vous jean luc mélenchon qu'on
avait présentée comme le premier le
principal opposant lui a encore un
avenir puisqu'il a reconnu à la fois son
blues et que emmanuel macron avait
marqué le point oui je n'ai pas senti
résigné non plus enfin si vous l'avez
senti résigné moi je ne le sens pas
résigné écouter ce qu'il a un avenir ou
pas c'est pour ça que je me préoccupe
plutôt de bien sûr dernière que celui
que celui des autres dans l'instant
voilà ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
nous ne rentrons pas dans l'opposition
de la même manière que la france est
soumise passeront de 300 de la butée à
30 il n'avait pas débuté il y en a 17
ils ont leurs corps de doctrine un c
pour les partis de gauche aux élections
présidentielles ils ont leurs leaders
donc je dire dans ce début de
quinquennat de naître dans l'hémicycle
eh bien on ne pouvait pas être dans la
même situation est la même posture mais
je peux vous dire qu'avec cette loi avec
notre travail d'opposition avec la
refondation qui est à l'oeuvre dans les
histoires vous ont permis et bien voilà
c'est quand même savez c'est une grande
liberté que d'être basso ses listes en
liberté pour inventer l'avenir merci
beaucoup ancien rennais d'avoir été avec
nous aujourd'hui merci stéphanie bonsoir
à tous et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
là